hello everyone and welcome to a
wonderful game that comes as a
suggestion from a subscriber that it is
from 2005 from the European Championship
we just covered the European
Championship it ended uh two days ago
but this is from European Championship
2005. uh Magnus pretty much just got his
Grand Master title he got it in 2004 and
he's facing Russian Grand Master
alexanderia zanzi who's been a grand
master since 2001 I believe uh Magnus is
15 uh when when this was played the
asantev is around 19 and it's a really
really awesome game uh where uh
Alexander puts a whole lot of pressure
on Magnus but Magnus somehow finds these
uh incredibly ridiculous complicated
moves and he he just comes up on top so
it's a really fun game uh you guys will
enjoy it let's check it out here we have
a D4 by Alexandra and the Magnus goes
for the Queen's Indian defense and then
Knight to F6 is not the Queen's Indian
defense but he will go for it E6 Knight
to F3 and now B the Queen's Indian
defense we have Pawn to A3 the second
most popular option against the The
Queen's Indian and Bishop to B7 we
ignite the C3 D5 we have characters
captures and now uh Bush captures
captures Bishop to D2 and now Bishop to
E7 so all very standard stuff even by
today's standards we have Queen to C2
Knights the D7 and now Ponte E4 chasing
away magnus's Knight so he trades on C3
captures captures with the bishop with
castles and now Rook to D1 we have
rooked the C8 by Magnus and now we have
Bishop to C4 yeah you you might think
why not Bishop to D3 isn't that um a
better idea uh the problem is C5 uh
that's uh that's why Bishop to C4 is
played first now after Bishop to C4 you
don't really have C5 as black if you try
C5 now then D5 happens in Bishop gives
additional support to the D5 Square so
that's why the weird move order Bishop
to C form we have Knight to F6 by Magnus
now putting pressure on the E4 pawn and
only now Bishop back to D3 and now
Magnus strikes with C5 against the
center D captures and C5 now you have to
be a little bit careful as The Rook is
nicely aligned with the queen but Magnus
boldly captures on C5 with the Rook
there are no good discoveries for this
bishop for the moment so here we have
castles and now Queen to A8 getting the
queen out of Harm's Way and also uh
creating this powerful battery along
this diagonal we have Rook after E1 and
now there is a game that was played in
uh 1996 it was played between Vladimir
kopian and vassil ivanchuk where Rook
the d8 was played that game in the
dinner draw but here Magnus played Rook
F the C8 and it is now as of move 16
that we have a completely new game so
let's see how it continues of course you
have to move the queen from the C file
Queen to E2 and now rooked back to C7 if
this was played by a let's say Maxima
Shiela gravity no doubt we would see
something like catfish cappers and
captures uh also the A3 Pawn would be
weak and you would have to connect the
past pawns on the queen side which is
definitely a good idea but also maybe
just A4 and then Bishop B5 it's hard to
say if you will be able to claim this
Pawn so Magnus decides to go back Rook 5
to C7 and now Pawn to A4 you don't want
to allow such a thing in the future Pawn
A6 with knights the E5 and now Bishop
the f8 now you can see that the bishop
pair is very nicely placed uh we have
Knight the C4 puts pressure on on the B6
pawn and this will win the material so
Magnus needs to defend the V6 Pawn
Knight the D7 was played now Queen E3
piling up on the B6 Pawn uh Rook to C6
defending and now Bishop back to F1 this
opens up an attack from The Rook to the
Knight on D7 knife the C5 and now Pawn
to A5 uh again putting pressure on that
B6 Pawn so Magnus has to capture B
captures an A5 and now Knight captures
an A5 Rook has to move so Rook back to
C7 and now Bishop to E5 again puts
pressure on magnus's Rook Rook to D7 and
now the mighty B4 and here it's very
hard to decide what to do with white
Magnus first trades a pair of Rooks Rook
captures on D1 Rook captures and now uh
the safest way to play this is Knight to
the A4 but it's such a weird move to
play Magnus decides to play Pawn to F6
and now Bishop to F4 uh here you could
uh you could gain some Advantage with B
captures on C5 and then after Magnus
capture that played as a very annoying
Bishop C4 move it's not easy to defend
the E6 Pawn black will constantly have
to worry about the past C Pawn also The
Rook is coming to D7 so it would be it
would be very very hard to defend this
but the Magnus was able to trick him he
played Pawn to F6 Bishop back to F4 and
now Knight captures an E4 still Rook to
D7 puts pressure on the bishop on B7 uh
Rook to C3 attacks Alexander's Queen on
E3 with Queen to E1 and again what is
Magnus doing here F3 is coming this will
remove the defender of The Rook how will
how will he defend this and also the
bishop is still hanging and Magnus here
plays Bishop to D5 he allows Pawn to F3
and this is what he had in mind Pawn to
F3 now comes Bishop captures on B4
not just attacking the Knight but also
threatening some very nasty discoveries
here but Alexander plays it precisely F
captures on e4 and now Bishop captures
on e4 notice that if you capture on A5
yes you still kind of have some nasty
discoveries but after captures on D5 uh
there's just no good move here for
example E5 Bishop to D2 and all of
Black's Contra play is gone this is just
completely winning for white so Magnus
plays Bishop captures on e4 and now
Bishop to D2 now now what do you play
here Magnus plays Bishop to C5 with
check uh he uses all of this to align
his Bishops perfectly in a in a very
deadly Fashion King the H1 and now look
at magnus's next move he plays a rook to
F3 and it's a weird move but also you
you can feel that it's a powerful move
the problem is his position is lost but
only if white finds uh a very particular
move basically the only move that wins
in the game otherwise he's just worse so
feel free to pause the video and try to
find the winning idea for Alexander
while I give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
weird move and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is a move with
the Knight back Knight back to B7 uh it
wasn't played in the game uh but this
would make things uh or life very
difficult for magnets because now not
only is The Rook hanging also the bishop
is hanging because the queen isn't
defending the bishop so what could you
play here only move is Bishop captures
on B7 and now comes the really hard move
to find the first move was kind of easy
now Bishop to A5 only winning move Queen
captures an E6 check is fine but King h8
you have nothing but after Bishop A5
there is no defense against Rook 38 will
win the black queen uh that there's just
no no way to stop that you could try
Queen to A7 but then then you just get
checkmated Queen E6 check now the back
rank has been vacated Rook to d8 Dasher
blocks and now Rook captures and f8 will
be Checkmate so that's why after this
Rook to F3 move uh the absolute best was
Knight to B7 but he didn't play it he
played something else he played Bishop
to C3 probably with the idea of going
Bishop to D for next to counter magnus's
strong Bishop on this diagonal but now
it is Magnus who is completely winning
the tables has now completely shifted so
feel free to pause the video once again
and now find the winning idea for Magnus
while I give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on finding this
incredible idea and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is of
course a rook to F2 this is what Magnus
played and now it is evident that there
is no Escape now the bishop D4 is pretty
pointless as the G2 Pawn is being
pressured Three Times by The Rook bishop
and queen so Rook to D2 was played but
it doesn't really help all that much uh
Magnus just played Bishop captures on G2
with check and it was in this position
on move 36 that Alexander riazan
resigned to the game as there is nothing
more to be done here the problem is okay
if Bishop captures then Queen captures
his Checkmate but if the King goes to G1
then Rook captures an F1 is Checkmate
now it's check from rook and the bishop
on C5 and now of course the King has
nowhere to go yeah it is Checkmate uh so
yeah a very very weird game like I said
I have no idea if maybe this was a time
trouble issue after Rook the F3 because
if you don't find Knight to B7 you just
don't move you don't move because you
know that everything has is just lost so
I imagine maybe it was a time travel
thing or maybe he just missed Rook to F2
again without Rook to F2 Magnus doesn't
really have all that much so really
complicated game but you can see how
yeah not just one player having the
bishop pair but both player is having a
deadly Bishop pair can make it a whole
lot difficult to calculate everything
properly and yeah if you guys are
interested here are the standings of the
tournament uh let me just load that up
uh It Was Won by uh liviudetarnesipano
these are the top 10 of the event
lividity Spano won the European
Championship 2005 with 10 out of 13 with
a perfect uh perfect tournament seven
wins zero losses and six draws uh rajabo
in second place with nine and a half out
of 13 and Levon arunan with a 9 out of
13 in third place or basically sharing
third place with the Sergey kariak and
Vaseline and
um
also Alexander and Alexander moisenko
and then in 10th place we have vadimilov
uh Magnus nowhere near the the top ten I
I don't think he was even in the in the
top 20 here and it was a pretty big
tournament 229 players but yeah he did
get this beautiful win uh and I mean a
complicated one but definitely beautiful
one uh so yeah that's the game hope you
hope you enjoyed it if you have any
other favorite long forgotten Magnus
Brilliance feel free to share so we can
all enjoy them I would like to thank
ravishing reptiles YouTube Ricky black a
live
and Matthew benowa for your contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check out my new wonderful
suggestions such as this one and
whatever else happens in the Chess World
uh thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day